from the rap CNN's Lisa France calls out
Matt Walsh's weird scientific objection
to a black Little Mermaid they have they
have laundered this story several times
now here's the story Matt Walsh says on
his show I don't care if if anyone of
any race is playing any character it's
basically how it was in the 90s and and
that's totally fine I just don't like
the double standard and for that matter
he's like can we talk about the science
of of a mermaid like underwater it
wouldn't make sense to have dark skin
because the sea creatures down there
have no pigmentation So Not only would
she be very pale she'd be translucent
translucent like some kind of horrifying
floating skeleton it was a joke it was
nonsense obviously The Little Mermaid
isn't a floating skeleton the next thing
that happens is they say Matt Walsh
makes racist Claim about Little Mermaid
they omit stuff then you get David
French being like here's Matt Walsh's
argument for why Ariel should be white
which he never said now the story has
become his weird scientific objection to
a black little mermaid when his whole
when his his whole point was he's okay
with actors of any race playing any
character they have laundered the story
to that great this is the media Now CNN
Lisa France calls out so what's going to
happen now they've laundered the story
it's completely fabricated and someone's
gonna be watching CNN drooling staring
at the screen confused and they're going
to say Matt Walsh said racist things and
they're gonna go whoa and that's how you
entrench the call Tim that doesn't make
sense though because the idea of a
little mermaid is racist because a woman
doesn't just have to be a maid she can
be uh the CEO she can be the president
she doesn't have to be a maid so I don't
like Disney doing that these little
girls are smart a lot of them just
because they're good at cleaning and
cooking doesn't mean that she has to be
a maid hold on there a minute I just
kind of thought of something so uh it's
actually from the word Maiden
does that mean the word made literally
just means young woman so when you're
like I gotta call a maid you're
literally saying I need a young woman
yeah yeah that's what it is yeah that's
kind of funny that liking it all the
time young woman is synonymous with
person who cleans your house yeah isn't
that crazy so here's what happens right
uh the Newsweek runs this story Matt
Walsh slammed for saying black Little
Mermaid isn't scientific okay Matt
Walsh's actual segment and quote was
hilarious he said if anything not only
should The Little Mermaid be pale she
should actually be translucent and
adding that if you look at deep sea
creatures they're like translucent they
have no kind of pigmentation whatsoever
and they're just like these horrifying
skeletons floating around in the ocean
he's not wrong that's what the Little
Mermaid should look like she should be
totally pale and skeletal where you can
see her skull through her face and that
would actually be a little version of
Little Mermaid I would watch me too so
this is
Cassandra McDonald formerly Cassandra
Fairbanks posted it's like an angler
fish looking aerial with like purple
hair this is the one I really like
though
it's good The Little Mermaid and it's
this horrifying looking skeletal monster
I love how he made a joke about The
Little Mermaid having her skull be
visible through her face and then the
entire the meat is just like we got him
and they run this crazy story about him
being racist when you I love these
stories because when we can drive to the
root of how they lied it gives you an
understanding as to how the media in
every facet is lying to you about what's
going on in the world
um Matt Walsh also called himself a
translucent rights activist which is
important to bring up here but I think
this whole thing is a distraction I
think this from the very beginning I
think this is just something to waste
our time and I think Disney loves this I
think this is the way that now the major
movie industry knows that they could
sell the movie by creating controversy
what better way to create a controversy
than to create this artificial character
that of course they know people are
going to debate they know people are
going to have a conversations about they
know is going to spur on debate people
call this uh fan baiting and I think
this is all marketing this is all PR are
by Disney trying to of course promote
their movie at the end of the day this
is what it is I love
I love this
like it's our love I love these months
it's Ariel with like an angler fish
light and like big teeth and big bulbous
eyes uh one thing we're not talking
about the elephant in the room that all
Disney movies are based on trauma-based
mind control with the main character
losing a very close-loved person at the
very beginning like they're a parent or
their discipline oh yeah everyone let's
go to a Little Mermaid her mom yeah her
mom died yep Little Mermaid's mom dies
how did she die she gets caught in like
a trawler's net a fishing net yeah she
gets eat Jason Momo she gets put in
Jason Momoa domestic violence terrible
it's all trauma-based mind control it is
it is but it really is the Disney stuff
is because it's supposed to you know
also that's how they get the little kids
hooked by the trauma it creates like
this cortisol response a little kid's
like what I'm so sad but then it you
know has this like fake you know uh
fairy tale what happened to Ariel's mom
I'm not sure I don't think they ever say
do they I think we should make a short
where she gets caught in like a trawler
she's like oh then she goes right into
the grinder
Bumblebee tuna
but while this story is most I love the
humorous output you know with the
ridiculous looking aerial but no this is
an important point because when you're
reading a story about say Donald Trump
this is how you understand you can you
can drive from this story to its root
and because it's a little mermaid it's
something that regular people might
actually understand if you go to them
and you say hey did you know the the
Shinzo Abe hoax and they'll go The Who
The Shins Japan and Trump and the fish I
don't know what you're talking about you
go to and say you know the new Little
Mermaid movie yeah you hear about that
racist guy yeah look at this yep
something they've already been primed to
like they've heard right it's like when
um that dude from flecka's talks goes in
the street and says who's George
Washington like I don't know name the
Kardashian sisters and they're like oh
it's so Chloe yeah you know it all so I
I like this you know and also I'm having
a good time it's funny Matt's a funny
guy I I love lgbtq Nation wrote that he
was having a meltdown and then like
anybody who knows Matt Walsh is like a
Matt Walsh the most extreme version of
his meltdown is him going to be going
like huh okay yeah
yeah I I think you're right I I think
that it's always great to show people
the extremes a left go to set in a
narrative and how much the media just
actively will push something that's just
the complete opposite of what the case
may be and when it's funny it plays more
also and that's where you get this where
this will stick in people's heads of
another outrageous attempt to to make
Matt Walsh into something that he's not
so I mean hey it kind of checks all the
boxes to illustrate that it's amazing
that they're like he said a mermaid
shouldn't be black and they stop because
if they did the full context they'd be
like he said the mermaid should have
translucent skin with her skull being
exposed you'd be like I don't understand
how that's racist what is that so that's
why he made himself a pro-translucent
activist and everyone's saying he's
pro-trans so yeah but guys in 20 years
Little Mermaid will be transgender
20. do you think it'd be less that's too
long well when did when did the it was
1989 when the little mermaid cartoon
came out so it's actually been you know
it's been like 30 it's been 33 years
well yeah you're right so we're in the
acceleration uh phase of this where yeah
it'll probably be two years and and
Ryan here is to talk about education but
Ryan what do you think that we went
wrong we're in schools now they have
these you know transition closets or
these t-shirts you see Libs of tick tock
like why do you think they're so
motivated to indoctrinate kids it's
almost like they're coordinated or
almost 100 as coordinated you know I
mean and that's where you look at this
and and I'll give you an example of what
happened in Oklahoma we had a teacher
who was giving kids access to
pornography in the classroom that didn't
make sense like what so hey so I go out
and go okay she said she broke the law
she said that she's going to keep
breaking the law then she's shown
pornography to kids when you take her
teaching certificate that's literally
what the law said yeah okay right
well then the media starts in this
narrative that I'm after all the
teachers I'm like not after all the
teachers I'm after one teacher's
teaching certificate because she was
giving access to pornography and they go
well that's censorship I go no
no what is appropriate for kids in
school is not censorship right real
quick yeah was she a government employee
yes it's not it's not you can call it
censorship sure but it's not a violation
of one a or first when the government
tells the government it can't do
something that's exactly right but again
so then well I'll take it a step further
then the media in Oklahoma run this list
of quote banned books in Oklahoma yeah
it came from an international group that
said hey we've looked at Oklahoma's law
so we think these books are banned there
and they run it for a week and I'm going
out there every every day going we don't
have any banned books we just have a
mine you cannot give pornography to a
minor law that's like been around like
every state for 30 years I mean but but
the media has run with this narrative
and tried to paint it as well hey if
you're going to question her you're
going after all teachers that's not true
and number two you're trying to ban but
I mean they're going hey he's going to
ban Huckleberry Finn and why do they
always ban Huck fans that has the n-word
I guess yeah that's why there is but I
mean just that that book is required
reading and I see 1984 and in Brave New
World they're getting banned why because
of predictive programming why I mean why
I mean why do you think those are
getting bigger and again I don't you
know they set this up they're not
fiction anymore
what's the cat out of the bag I guess
but you know it's not Republicans it's
not conservatives it's not Libertarians
pushing Banning of books there's a
difference between having conversations
about I mean again and I had someone I
had a reporter say hey but you know kids
can get porn on their phone I go hold on
so the argument is yeah it's out there
so we should have it in the school
library for second graders yeah that's
outrageous and to your point it's part
the left is intentionally trying to
indoctrinate kids push them away from
their parents because guess what you go
home and tell your parents about it they
go wait what's going on so the kid
further withdraws from their parents
they want there to be no hey male female
they're those don't matter there's
really no gender or there's no sex it's
fluid and it becomes this confusing
we're gonna have the most confused
generation in the history of the United
States there was a story about a woman I
was reading it was I think it was a
social media post and she said that her
daughter was in school and the school
had been transitioning her daughter
without her knowing her daughter was
growing increasingly depressed and what
had happened what it seems like from the
story I mean maybe it's not true it's an
anecdote is that the girl was becoming
depressed because the school was telling
her and encouraging her and pushing her
and everyone around her is goading her
and saying yes yes and then she
eventually told her mom she didn't want
to go to school anymore because it was
giving her anxiety and then as soon as
she stopped going to school she she
stopped all the pronoun stuff she
stopped the transition stuff because
apparently the story is she never wanted
to but she was being pressured to that's
kind of creepy and scary yeah I mean
it's become you know you have activists
that are pushing it and I mean again
these are kids I mean this is probably
you know my background is as a teacher
you have to take responsibility very
seriously as a teacher to go these are
young impressionable kids I'm not going
to sit here and push an ideology or push
a point of view on them I want them to
have multiple points of view and come to
their own conclusion but now you've got
the left who's decided we're going to
address Folks up and pretend to be
teachers then they're going to go in
there and they're going to push this and
then you create this culture of it to
your point young people are going to be
so confused it causes depression it
causes frustrations and it doesn't equal
a job thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there